a memorial service for a family that
drowned in one of the worst migrant boat
tragedies in the Eastern Mediterranean
the relatives weren't able to bury their
dead because they live in Syria's
opposition controlled Norse
the bodies were found by the authorities
off the coast of Syria
I lost my daughter her husband and their
three children none of them were old
enough to be in school we also lost four
members of our extended family someone
we know identified them at hospitals
they were born refugees in neighboring
Lebanon where the economic collapse made
life extremely difficult
the family had no choice but to take a
risk to reach Europe to live a life of
dignity
bodies and the few survivors were taken
to hospitals in regime controlled Tartus
not all of the Syrian victims were
refugees
Syrian State media shared photos of
residents of Latakia who had crossed
into Lebanon to board the boat poverty
and unemployment rates are also high in
government areas
the authorities in Damascus are not
releasing bodies until they are
identified by their families at
hospitals this means some syrians aren't
able to go in particular those in the
opposition those who Escape military
service during the war and those with no
documents to return to Lebanon
the bodies and survivors brought back to
Lebanon so far have been those of
Palestinian and Lebanese Nationals
those involved confirmed to us that no
Syrian victims were returned
God bless his soul is a Syrian who lived
here with his Lebanese wife
we try to resolve his case but I think
they buried him today in Syria his
family they tried to repatriate his body
but you know paperwork takes a lot of
time
there's also been little information
about the 11 syrians who survived with
some activists saying some have been
detained
there was one Survivor in a family of
ten my sources told me he has been
detained he's from the Eastern
Countryside of idlib also syrians and
Syrian Palestinians are being guarded by
military police and intelligence in
Tartus hospitals
the Damascus government hasn't responded
to these accusations and state media
says all survivors have been discharged
from hospitals but it appears for some
syrians the tragedy may not be over
Beirut